[Music]
all right let's go to nicole
in colorado springs what's up nicole
not much how's it going good good good
good okay that's much much much better
um so what's up
um we my husband and i we are expecting
our second baby early next year awesome
and we are super excited about that but
i am having a lot of anxiety about
sending this baby to daycare our first
baby was a pandemic baby so there was so
much anxiety around that
and we dropped her off at seven weeks
old we were sleeping a couple hours a
night and it was possibly the worst day
of my life
i'm just like
i
don't know if i want to do that again
but i have a different job now and i
love it my career is back on track after
pandemic i love my co-workers i have a
great team flexible schedule like
everything is going so well
and i just i've looked up all the
research and i don't know is there is
there a good time to send a baby to
daycare is daycare really the gulag for
children like
is there is there a way i can have it
all
that is the magic question that's the
magic question hey i'm laughing i i used
to
so i worked at university i would i
would work in housing and i would help
with move in every year
and um
i would just hug these dads who dropped
their kids off and they would be i mean
these big tough texas dudes and they
would be boo-hooing and i would just my
eyes would be rolling out of the back of
my head like oh my gosh
and then when hank came along he was
like six weeks or six months or
something and i drove him to like a
tuesday thursday school at some local
church in my community
and i sat in the parking lot and wept
it was like coming to an end man i
remember that day so so much man
um jesus louise um
all right
here's what i want to do
i want to avoid
the first half of your question
okay here's why
there's so much competing drama
when it comes to research
yes there's so much competing drama when
it comes to
uh
gender equity discussions in fairness
and with the workplace quote unquote
owes us and
is it best for our kid etc right there's
so much stuff around that right and then
there's the other complicating factor
here's what i think i think that if we
say out loud
ideally
somebody stay a parent stays with that
kid
yeah then
the millions and millions and millions
of people who
can't afford to do that
yeah get thrown into a shame blender
and so instead of having that hard
conversation
everybody just stays away from the
conversation right so here's what i'm
saying yeah it doesn't matter what my
opinion is on that particular part of it
what's more important is your second the
second part of your question
yeah can you have it all
and so hear me say this you know this
and maybe it will help
to have some
just
a male say it out loud maybe that will
help i don't know if it will yeah um
you have entered into an industrial
guilt complex
that is designed intentionally to make
you as a modern woman who is a mother
and an extraordinary professional
never be able to put both feet on the
ground
no because if you put both feet on the
ground you'll quit buying crap
and you'll quit reading everything
seriously i'm totally serious
the way to keep a mother off kilter and
buying things is to tell her you are
failing your kid
and then you stay home and then to tell
her immediately
you were failing generations of women
who went before you and fought for the
right for you to go dude what do you do
right there's no way to win
and when you're at home you're looking
at the best way to do this i'm gonna
approach it like a career
and then you realize oh there's no way
to you can't win right i mean there's
just so many
and then i'm just gonna i'm gonna
approach a career i'm gonna find a great
sitter i'm gonna find a great nanny
would it
and the whole time you're like wow huh
that meeting was more important than my
kid
yes oh this meeting was way more
important than spending an hour with and
then you sit with your kid and it's the
most boring time ever it's the worst
it's the worst
and then at the end of that boring hour
your kid just craps everywhere and you
think
i would have done way better if i was at
work like doing things that contributed
to so right so you know all this stuff
i'm just saying it out loud so you know
you're not crazy
yeah there's not a way to win and to
answer your question no you cannot have
it all
unless you are a bajillionaire
and most of us are not
are you one of
those we are not we are in a good place
like we could make it like a
we could make it without my income like
we just wouldn't have the extra to save
etc etc okay is that a true statement or
is that a dramatic statement meaning
ah we could make it
if you changed your life up would you
all be just fine
oh yeah a hundred percent like i i'm
always skeptical and people are like
well we can't afford it i'm like i want
to see the numbers like we are dedicated
like we could do it
there are i i i they are there i've
talked to a bunch of them that i look at
it and say i don't know how you can stay
in this state unfortunately yeah right
100 100 i have friends that are that way
and it's like and that's where like you
said the guilt thing it's just it just
never stops ridiculous to do to people
who are like oh my god you don't stay
home with your kid it's like well some
people don't have the option there you
go so
i would have the option i think it's
better for my mental health and my
sanity to at least work part-time okay
so i think that's what i'm leaning
towards would it be
like i keep want to go back to the
research so because i've read so many
articles would it be better to find an
in-home daycare provider if we could
versus a daycare center like i love our
daycare and our daughter has
a great routine i can always count on
them to be there like she's so smart i
think i
i don't have any of that data in front
of me okay just been on top of my head i
know how important routine in
environment is
i also know how important stimulation
and social engagement is
and so i can flip a coin on that one
right now now somebody may send me and
if it's out there feel free to email it
to me um the last literature i read
um
and i don't even know when the study was
published and i don't even know the
efficacy of the study had some
correlation between moms who stay at
home and like test scores when the kid
was in 10th grade or something like that
yeah and so um
fine fair cool
um
i think it's gonna cut
oh now you're getting a whole other
soapbox here's the deal i know i know we
more data is not a good antidote to
anxiety
okay
i know it is i know it is you are going
to article yourself to death
and never truly ask yourself what do i
want to do
and then here's the scariest thing and
we are not taught this skill in our
modern world
live with the consequences of our
choices
yeah
and so
at some point you're going to put the
articles down stop taking your
girlfriends out the coffee and saying
okay what do you think like how did it
work for you you have to stop all that
you have to quit going on walks with
your husband at night going but i think
and i don't know and he's just like i
don't just pick something right
exactly um at some point you're gonna
have to exhale and say
what i want counts
i am a good mom
and i'm a really good employee
here's what i think is best for this
particular season right now
and i'm gonna give it a shot for six
months
and if it's an absolute disaster
great i got some more data
and which you happen to just love love
loved just like me by the way
and i'm then gonna move on and i'm gonna
go back to work full-time and it's gonna
hurt but it's right or i'm gonna stay at
home full-time and it's gonna hurt and
it's right or i'm gonna muddle through
it and i'm gonna work part-time
it's you're you're making a choice right
this second
that is not a forever choice
it's the best choice to make right now
for you your husband your family these
kids i mean you know what i mean
yeah and so
take the burden off of uh if i do this
one thing wrong it's all it's not
it's not
is that fair
yeah that little kid's gonna love you
who told you that what you want doesn't
count
oh it's it's something my therapist and
i've been working on for quite a while
now
[Music]
so what is your what does your therapist
think you should do
generally we've just gotten better about
me getting clear about what i want okay
and then telling the people close to me
what i want that includes like my
parents
why why would you tell them why'd you
tell anybody in the world other than
your husband
um because some of the um decisions like
would involve my parents and so like if
we have expectations they're like these
are the needs that i need you to meet or
these are like our boundaries those are
the things that i would need to tell
them
can i save you the next 20 years of
sadness and guilt and shame
your parents don't get a vote
take them out of the i take them out of
your voting machine
okay and that one hurt because we've
been doing that one for a while i know
take them out they don't get a vote
because parents
there's a lot that goes into that and
you'll learn this
as you have your own kids but they
have different reasons for making
different decisions
and you can love them and honor them and
listen
and then you got to do what's best for
you and your husband and they don't get
a vote
yeah
you know what i mean
you may invite them into a certain
situation or a certain moment or a
certain conversation and which is
wonderful and great but at the end of
the day you and your husband make this
call
and then you can let them know hey
here's what we're gonna do we'd love you
to be involved here and then they get to
make grown-up decisions and say we're
not gonna be a part of that and that's
gonna hurt and sting and be sad and all
that stuff and then we're gonna move on
with our lives
yeah right
will you say it out loud they don't get
a vote
they don't get a vote
i'm working on cancelling the inner
dialogue too
that i grew up with
daycare is for bad mom and it's morally
superior to home with your kid no matter
what it cost you right
i'm sorry you're carrying that stuff
around
thank you
those stories you were born into the
stories people told you because those
stories become the ones you tell
yourself right
yeah yeah
so here's the deal those stories were
told to you and they have a period at
the end of them
right
those stories were told they happened
now you can spend a whole bunch of
energy trying to go back and edit those
sentences or you can
do the one thing that your two little
kids and your husband are desperate for
you to do which is to spend your energy
writing new sentences
here's what comes here's what comes next
is that cool
that's cool
um for whatever it's worth i talk to a
lot of folks behind closed doors who are
struggling and
um
it's not rare that i talk to a parent
that um
we have to i have to report we have to
call we have to get involved with and so
hear me say this
your two kids are really lucky to have
you
thank you real lucky
now go make the right choice and don't
screw this up nicole
no pressure
no pressure
look hey give yourself six months okay
okay give yourself six months and say
i'm gonna work part time i'm gonna work
from home for six months and then i'm
gonna
re-re-imagine it
um my friend eva who's a writer who's
brilliant um she worked with me for the
last couple of years
she was one of the few people in what i
would call in my trust circle i would
write a talk and that she would say john
this isn't funny this is dumb like you
think this is so dramatic it's not it's
over it's just annoying
um she was
uh an absolute professional gift and
then she had baby number four
and
um she came back rocking and rolling
we're on to the next
and then she just went home
she had his time
and it didn't make leaving an awesome
work environment um easy
no and this is the season she's chosen
and she's gonna do other things and work
from home all that to say but see what
i'm saying like
every mom's got to make a different call
my wife has gone through various
variations and right now she's in a
season i don't expect it to last that
way forever none of us do it's just the
season right now and sometimes it's been
full time and sometimes it's 100 stay at
home it's just been a fluctuation in in
time and place and season
the greatest gift you can give nicole is
some grace
yeah
you're mean to nicole stop
if hey if your husband
was out like at a tj maxx because let's
be honest that's where he shops i can
already tell if he's hanging out tj maxx
and he heard somebody talk to his wife
the way you do he'd go to jail
he would go to jail right
right don't talk to his wife like that
he wouldn't marry someone who's a
goofball you know what i mean
yeah don't talk to your kid's mom that
way
yeah
give nicole some grace and give nicole
some trust
okay and i know those are hard you gotta
practice those things because they're
tough those are hard
you gotta practice we're getting better
i know but listen um and you can tell
your counselor i said this
a lot of my colleagues in the mental
health profession
do a lot of thinking and talking about
thinking
at some point you got to start doing and
then
practicing
okay yeah
yeah
so make a call and sit with it for a few
days are you gonna quit your job
no
you're not
no okay are you going to be 100
full-time stay-at-home mom
no
look at that
are you going to work full-time or
part-time
i think part-time time
[Music]
no here's what's beautiful about that
you nicole are gonna disappoint
everybody
so great
you can disappoint your parents you're
gonna disappoint your workplace you're
gonna disappoint everybody except for
the four people that actually matters
for
true right
right congratulations nicole
thank you yeah i mean i mean honestly
you're you're a free woman
congratulations
and put a note on the calendar
six months from the day your baby's born
and say we're gonna revisit this we're
gonna revisit this in month five and
that gives us about 30 days to talk
about how's it going how do we feel
um how's our finances how's like we're
in an incredibly fortunate position
right now financially
um and
then we'll re-imagine it and go from
there
low pressure
low pressure
and everybody listening um i will do
this i'll make the commitment to get
into that scholarship i do get that
question um with some regularity and so
i'll dig into it and i'll all i'm not
afraid of the conversation about it um i
don't want to wade into
a bunch of social drama around the
science of it around the shame of it
around
what might be optimal versus what people
have to do to survive
right and there's just all that gets
dumped into a big bucket and then people
just want to throw grenades and i'm not
i'm not interested in that
um but i will dig into it um
and to all you moms out there i'm sorry
that we've created a world
that is focused solely on making you
feel guilty so you buy stuff to feel a
little bit less guilty
my hope and prayer and dream for you
guys is y'all
we rally around and create a world where
y'all can
feel free to trust yourselves
and to listen to yourselves and to act
on that and then to say that
i tried that i didn't like him and try
something else and then we celebrate
that and we don't go ooh told you
and
soon to be grandma and grandpa
your guilt doesn't help
let's just dial it back about 40 or 50
percent